but these are all the things that is the
work in progress
that we'll continue to see durant count
it at a foul
and just once again we talk about this
so often but once kevin durant squares
you up and faces you there's nothing you
could do
so kemp burch has come in and he's made
some things happen seven points
harden the euro for two
the beard going to the basket harden's
eyes
in this play he's looking gets it back
wide open look for jeff green
rebounded by hardin
lob it up oh green finishes
it looks like that ball might float out
of bounds instead
greene snares it and lays it in in one
motion
durant crosses takes it all the way
absolutely dynamic and
knotted up at 81 a piece two for one
opportunity
harden king of the two for one a three
bullseye for the beard rebound fought
for perry nice effort
as he out rebounded clark right down the
middle
fake shot is good for james harden
time inside outside
kevin durant bottoms
harden against ross step back jay
sweet james harden
from downtown
[Applause]
the human torch
[Applause]
durant fades connects kevin durant
from all angles and what a nice blitz
there on terence ross
but he does he just faces he squares you
up
this is the best offensive showing the
magic have had in quite some time
and say this but they've lost four
straight all by double digits
kevin durant a downtown hit for k.d